تتقدم القوات الأوكرانية الأجنبية بالقرب من
باكموت بينما تقول كييف إن
جيش موسكو يتراجع في جميع
ساحات القتال تقريبًا
والآن أصبحت العاصمة الروسية في
مرمى هجوم آخر بطائرة بدون طيار
يضرب مبنى شاهقًا
فجأة كان هناك هذا العذر
يقول السكان إن هناك شظايا زجاج
ثم تصاعد الدخان
بينما زعمت السلطات أنه تم إحباط الهجوم، حيث ألحقت
طائرة بدون طيار أضرارًا بمبنى
ضرب بالفعل قبل يومين في
مجمع يضم العديد من المكاتب الحكومية.
رسالة كييف إلى الكرملين بأن الحرب
قادمة إليهم،
وأعتقد أن موسكو ستخوض المزيد والمزيد من
الحرب على نفسها  الأراضي التي
يقولها المستشار الرئاسي وهذا ليس له علاقة
بأوكرانيا وحدها الآن وهذا يرجع إلى
الأهمية التاريخية لهذه
اللحظة إذا بدأت مثل هذه الحرب عليك أن
تتوقع أن هذه الحرب ستكون على أراضيك
آسف
أوكرانيا تستخدم بشكل متزايد طائرات بدون طيار ل
ضرب أهداف روسية داخل
روسيا وفي الأراضي التي تحتلها روسيا
سواء في الجو أو في الماء
بعد أن ضربت كييف جسر القرم قبل ثلاثة
أسابيع، وتقول موسكو الآن إن قواتها
أحبطت هجومًا بحريًا بطائرات بدون طيار على
سفن شحن في البحر الأسود رغم أن أوكرانيا
تنفي استهداف المدنيين.
سفن البحرية الروسية التي
رافقت النقل البحري اكتشفت
ودمرت جميع القوارب في الوقت المناسب، كما
يقول المتحدث، مع
تراجع القوات الروسية ببطء في
جنوب أوكرانيا، زيارة نادرة مزعومة على
خط المواجهة قام بها الجنرال بوتين الأعلى
فاليري جيراسيموف للحصول على التحديثات  يقول الروس من
القادة في منطقة زاباريسيا،
على الرغم من أنه ليس من الواضح أين ومتى تم
تصوير الفيديو بالضبط،
تحاول القيادة العسكرية الروسية
تصوير القوة والسيطرة حتى مع
شعور المزيد من الروس بأن الحرب
تقترب أكثر فأكثر فريد تيتان سي إن إن برلين